avez vous suivre au cours de langue à
l'école j'espère que oui parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous allez en avoir peur
c'est un jeu assez rigolo mais sur un
site ils vont nous dire des mots et on
va devoir alors allez on va devoir
deviner la langue je sais par exemple
qu'il ya des gens qui ont beaucoup de
mal à reconnaître le chinois du coréen
du japonais est pas moi et je vais vous
le prouver aujourd'hui par contre est
beaucoup plus lent que répète que je
n'ai probablement jamais entendu mais on
va faire ce qu'on peut osaka qui attend
le mec il a dit au sac à osaka c'est une
très grosse ville au japon wec du coup
tu connais mais je me suis dit c'est du
japonais japonais un peu un peu danois
quand même tu vois c'est bien évidemment
du danois avec ajusté entre les deux
autres kasenyi français ça c'est clair
ni japonais c'est dur du alors c'est dur
dubawi aspect d'urgence a offert un
bingo turley cheng bo gars très made in
sportives australiennes inclusive en
trophée aux occupants des deux
présidents alors c'est pas de l'italien
et c'est tout ce que j'en ai tiré comme
conclusion cédule [ __ ] c'est quoi çà
pour çà a tragic chez michael kors a
attrapé de schémas et je suis dit allez
alors je m'étais d'ailleurs catherine
d'inscrits ça me stresse mais qu est-ce
que c'est dur aux mains des troupes
appelées cyprien pour savoir j'aimerais
un homme et il est en vacances là il est
en vacances il pourra pas répondre chier
ou alors c'est du javanais ou du tamil
mais que sait même pas ce que ces vieux
non mais en tout cas spitalier tête
j'analyse aux [ __ ] c'était du rova
cyprien donc le roumain on dirait un
mélange d'allemand et d'italien ça donne
le romain c'est du russe
ah bah voilà voilà un jour on va voir
vont plus tard thibault alors devinez
devinez devinez
mais je suis en train de pourrir de
l'intérieur
c'est terrible
et ça c'est le 3ème youtuber de france
qui rigole pour deux minutes parce qu'il
a pété alors vous avez le choix
est ce que c'est de l'arabe est-ce que
c'est du chinois est-ce que c'est du
japonais ou est-ce que c'est dû soit là
là là où est-ce que c'est du swahili
bon c'est du japonais fin du suspense on
reconnaît beaucoup parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de coups de c qui colle aux
comics carrick à kolbsheim ashtar
yokogawa voilà alors est-ce du danois de
l'os éthique de lure du ou de l'ouzbek
voilà au mal et ce mot c'est à force
j'ai envie de croire aux danois encore
une fois [ __ ] c'est luce bec [ __ ] je
mets que j'ai jamais entendu un mec mais
c'est dur mais c'est super dur on dirait
un mélange de 2000 langue assez dur
je leur fais ma cadence est génial c'est
je vais craignant au [ __ ] c'était le
goût un mec c'est chaud là gros je
connais même pas c'est une futenma
située à la haine ou nationaux national
entre les hauts plateaux d eau les
barres n obtenaient hôpital j'adore si
toi là et nous national sachant que là
bas
j'aime bien méchante l'italien c'est
encore plus beau en battant des petites
anecdotes pour pour juste pour rire à
coup aussi au jour en route vous voyez
l'outil dont celui qui fait vous voyez
bien et m'a écouté je sais pas pourquoi
mais je suis tombé si cette vidéo où il
ya l'ulti hormis langues différentes et
au moment il a dit en espagnol j'ai
chialé de rire je sais pas c'était plus
fort que moi en fait c'est une belle
langue dans une situation hyper sérieux
je n'arrive pas y croire je pas pourquoi
donc dans plein de pays c'est ça c'est
la vo donc que même nous en france c'est
cette voie là qu'on a
et maintenant ça change des japonais
pourtant le japonais c'est une trop
belle robe style aux sorties devoirs ou
yahoo des lilas 80 piges voilà qu ils
ont géré ils ont géré la voix est trop
cool en fait j'ai tellement habitué au
garrot gâte c'est hélas il fait bon
d'accord ça donne de la désole se
retrouvent personnes me suis dans ce
délire et je suis seul n'est pas à
l'abri bord suivant alors chinois finish
swahili taille professeur geraint thomas
team à tarifa ya toujours du coin save
the queen
c'est pas chinois j'ai fini swahili
odieux mais le mec est à petit en ce
sens les muscles mais un titan j'adore
ce jeu je pourrais jouer pendant des
jours durant comme ma prof de sport et
ça plaît madame durand ah non mais voilà
on fait des big up six ans après voilà
madame durand c'est pour toi alors quel
langage c anglais lé 10 cents à 27
milles bas je suis bilingue désolé
excusez-moi j'ai reconnu au moins d'une
seconde pardon excusez moi pardon il dit
au cetic indie inadéquat indie games
comme les jeux ce qu'elle fait des
vidéos je rigole pas c'est faux
portugais non non c'est un pardon il y
avait beaucoup de com les portugais dans
le rouge sauf quand il parle bon quand
je ressors portugais une fois pardon
mais je le dis quand je vais rester en
portugais une fois par an la table à
côté juste derrière trois phrases et ma
conclusion c'est qu'il y beaucoup de
chutes dans le portugais est là y avait
pas mal de chemin mais c'était pas ça
donc chez bengali danois portugais ou
telugu est ce que je vais pouvoir me
racheter auprès de mes abonnés portugais
qui me font actuellement profondément la
gueule parce que ces bagues ali sans
prévenir il arrivait il a fait ces
brigades arabe hausse à corps et un
ukrainien où la [ __ ] la mecque
c'est soit ça soit sa hausse à m vous
avez compris la blague
attends je vais tout donner sur scène on
a été bien fait de m'engueuler déjà
commencé par deux pas m'engueuler ce que
j'avais le talent je pense pas que ce
soir pour moi c'est au sort merci à tous
mes potes robot qui m'ont montré la voie
en sortant des grosses stars foule à
aider voilà j'en ai tiré les conclusions
qu'il fallait c'est tout je suis un
connard j'adore mais [ __ ] c'est trop
bien en plus apte entraîne à essayer de
reconnaître les syllabes donc c'est
vraiment pas mal en fait norvégien
portugais tamil taille portugais on voi
le mec qui met bien avec les portugais
qui mangent à leur resto se voir ou pas
parce que la bouffe portugaise elle est
[Musique]
en tout cas ça a l'air d'être d'europe
c'est l'élan que c'est plus ou moins
dure à prendre selon chez but c'est quoi
le terme mais en gros il ya des cils par
exemple en français on a 80 % de
syllabes en commun avec le japonais donc
quand tu apprendras japonais tu vas pas
trop galérer à parler parce que sera
déjà dire les syllabes alors qu'à des
langues comme le portugais ou cd
syllabes qui a pas en france est
pratiquement s'est plaint de syllabes la
qualité juge a même pas soir c'était
qu'elle l'aide qu'ils étaient collés
parce qu'elle n'arrivait pas à trouver
du balayage à londres eh bien oui parce
que j'ai du mal à croire mais et je lui
ai dit en rigolant ben voilà il faut
faire un mille kilomètres bâtard de
fraude et précise les comme ça quand tu
la comprends ça on en ridicule je me
suis toujours demandé phonétiquement
quand un étranger nous entendez parler
mais qui parlent pas français commencent
à sonner par exemple nous conte italien
parle on kiffe mais ça se trouve qu à
l'américain entend italien parle et il
aime pas du tout fan en sait rien et
j'aimerais trop pouvoir pendant 4
secondes ne plus parler français pour
savoir ce que ça fait entendu français
mais sans le comprendre et ce que ce
soit bien ou pas voilà c'est un délire
bizarre je pense qu'on fini leur tu
voilà donc j'en perds tous mes abonnés
c'est très bien mais les années servant
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à aller mais
s'il vous a plu ne fait jamais ça avec
votre pantalon s'est fortement
déconseillée en santé notre prochaine
merci d'avoir regardé c'était super cool
schumannien du jeu dont la description
il n'est pas allé jouer ça vous
entraînera c'est super sympa et même
j'aime ça me fait plaisir de me dire que
dans la rue maintenant j'aimerais
peut-être un peu plus à savoir
d'où viennent les touristes oui c'est un
peu nul en fait à la peña prochaine de
leur savoir garder portez vous bien au
revoir
[Musique]